he's hosting the NBA draft on ESPN once
again Jalen Rose Michael Wilbon and Jay
Bilas and a cast of thousands with rece
Davis who's back here on the Rich Eisen
show how are you Reese I'm great rich
and I thoroughly enjoyed the Phil rant
while I was waiting - that was great
it's really ridiculous could you imagine
the oh look I'm going back and forth
with whether it's good that Dolan is
going to be with the with the straight
shots and delegating which is kind of
what you want your owner to do but you
know what do you think is what what is
Cuban not going to be locked in on what
Dallas is doing you know I mean Jeanne
bus with what you know the Lakers are up
to I mean this is absurd absurd and you
must be seeing it playing out on all the
back pages today they're in New York
yeah we we are and yes less on our graph
preview Shuai great delighted holding up
officially news with phil dressed as
santa claus and you know talking about
the possibility of creating porzingis
now I suggested that if they hadn't
dressed as Santa and if he indeed did
trait porzingis that they should a lump
of coal and Phil's stocking wrath you
want to pick pick up the phone on
restrike they're law he's on a cell
phone probably deep deep inside the
heart of Barclays center here of getting
ready for the for the draft tonight yeah
we saw that back page too may have been
just absolutely roasting Phil Jackson
unless he's just going ahead right now
and trying to send a message all the way
to Latvia to try and figure out his Rhys
back on their races back okay so you
were saying what would that the a lump
of coal should be in that stocking
wrapped in a pink slip because it just
it seems it seems irresponsible and and
look it maybe if there's some grand plan
I've heard people say today you know
he's trying to take that tactic that he
used often as a coaching shaming players
publicly to get them in line with what
he wanted but I think the difference
rich and you've alluded to this and the
Knicks and some of the other teams who
are trying to change directions
Philadelphia up
only now Los Angeles with magic and Rob
palinka they appear to have a plan I
don't know what the Knicks plan is other
than to take everybody off or you know
bully
Carmelo into accepting a train but you
know I just I think they're I think he's
like 86 games under 500 during his time
running the Knicks and some of that
unavoidable for the early times but it's
harder to see what the plan is
with the next senators with some of the
other Kings rhys-davies joining us here
on the Rich Eisen show from from
Barclays Center in Brooklyn so when do
the Sixers actually go on the clock you
go on the air at 7:00 Eastern is that
when shortly thereafter the Commissioner
puts the Sixers on the clock tonight
it'll be it'll be about 7:30 there's
technically the first half hours like a
graph preview show red and silver will
step up and he'll put the Sixers on the
clock and and the process then needs to
turn into pay off when they bring
marquel Fultz in well the conversation
is that the folks drafting is the
processes conclusion what are you
hearing about on that front from folks
like villus and and other insiders that
are around you Reese he's probably the
most complete player in the draft
although you know Jay pointed out last
night that he only shoots 65% from the
line and while his shot might look
better than Lonzo balls you know Lonzo
is a pretty effective shooter really
good athlete outstanding ball handler i
think it's going to help him because a
couple the Sixers that I talked to
earlier while very high I'm Ben Simmons
as the prospect did express some
reservation about him being you know the
sole ball handler and I think maybe
having Simmons and faults together over
the course of the next couple of years
if indeed can stay healthy which as much
as I like him as a player and as a guy
has not proven that he can do yet but if
he stays healthy and Simmons and Foltz
you know can come close to reaching
their potential that's a very good trio
around which to build and then and then
we were assuming Lonzo goes second
overall that would be a that would be
one of the first surprises if that does
not happen and if it does then the draft
essentially begins at three correct
isn't that's the way it's is that the
way you guys are looking at it tonight
yeah yeah I think so and I think the
Lakers are
really interesting because they you know
they've dumped some salary with Mozgov
gone and bringing in Lopez who's just
under contract for one more year
that will free them up for next year I
think there it seems most people believe
their ultimate dream is to somehow pull
off a deal to get Paul George maybe
pursue O'Brien and free agency next year
and then Avalon's oh there as there's
the reason to try to ultimately take a
swing at the Warriors at some point in
the future so and at three with Boston
selecting Ainge has accumulated all of
these assets and I thought Tom Penn is
our front office expert perhaps
described Boston best last year and I
think it still applies when he says for
the Celtics there's a whole lot of good
but not much great they need to take
some of these assets and some of these
draft picks that Ainge has accumulated
and turn that into great either by
selecting a great player whether that be
Jason Tatum or Josh Jackson presumably
or putting it together to make a trade
to get a great player because it wasn't
rich they were the number one seed in
the East it was obvious in the playoffs
they were they were vastly overachieving
I mean that's a credit to them but they
just don't quite have that that
greatness to you know look at them as a
crew championship contender while I say
that but I still applaud them for doing
what they did it's remarkable given
given their roster I think Reese Davis
in the Honda insider report the host of
tonight's draft coverage on ESPN joining
me here on the Rich Eisen show our poll
question today that's up on our app is
who's the most likely individual be
traded tonight Paul George Jimmy Butler
LaMarcus Aldridge
kristaps porzingis or nobody what do you
choose reason I'm I'm going to say
nobody tonight although I know the Paul
George stuff is still going I don't
think that's going to happen that
quickly I imagine it ultimately will
because they don't want to just let him
walk I'm going to say tonight among
those I'll say I'll say it's nobody and
then Paul George goes went when does
that happen you think I don't know I
think whenever they can squeeze out the
best deal and you know can the Lakers
you know the Lakers do have you know
they do have pick later on that they
could package together maybe it's you
know maybe it's a Julius ran
deal that could a decadent ice the
pacers that I think my guess is he will
go before the Stars next season probably
sometime you know in that free agency
period which opens July first
alright Rhys let's get inside the
broadcast right now which which
polysyllabic former Soviet bloc nation
player concerns you to pronounce the
most tonight Greece was just I was just
going through through some of those the
good thing is I've got them all
phonetically okay you're hooked on
ethically ready to go I think anyone
with a lot of vowels
you know you because it's early in the
draft it's not a you know Soviet bloc
connected but I'll say is that Neely
kina just because it's got that T in
there if you're not careful little the
silent key will get you every time trip
you up and after after we saw what
happened to our friend Joseph Buck over
the weekend are you well-versed on on
who's with whom the wags
draft wags if you will deceive no I I am
versed enough and also will be 1,000%
certain before I before I say that I
hated to see that happen happened to Joe
Cory people get better and everything's
great all the time he's always does yes
in all seriousness are there plans by
the product the producers at ESPN to
hand Lavar ball a microphone tonight for
near coverage we a kidding aside which
we do plan to talk to him not at the
expense of lonzo's moment this is about
tonight Lonzo but levar commands
attention and and people react and they
watch and they click and they listen you
know when he says stuff even if it is to
get angry at him but I think he's
interesting tonight because he was out
there before the draft a lot of it was
said saying my son is going to play for
the Lakers I'm going to keep saying
until I make it true and while certainly
you know that sort of uh you know just a
coincidence that it happened that way
it's interesting ok and with with the
notable exception of a couple of highly
offensive things he said most notably on
Colin Cowherd show I guess and a couple
of other times for the most part he's a
WWE character you know he's a he's a
hype man
he you know he's out there you know
trying to build a little bit of a
business I don't know whether he's
popping up his training business or
trying to get this big ball of brand off
the ground what I really want to know
the only question I don't know if I'll
get a chance to talk to a bar tonight I
want to know about this huge thing I
mean how does this work did he did he
hire a cobbler and put him in the garage
you know where's the shoe being made how
does one go that say hey I'm gonna have
someone building a shoe you know I just
that's the one thing I want to ask okay
so and then and then when it is all said
and done tonight you're there for all
four the four first second round and
then and then a post and then and then
what's what's next for you college
football yeah Terry on the bass to
college football just around the corner
a la Reese just hearing those two words
seriously I just I just uh I just really
enjoyed hearing those two words back
they they they are lyrical aren't they
they just sort of soothes the soul yes
by the way I don't know if you heard
when he called into my show and I will
give this to you for your for your game
for your gameday coverage later on in
the fall I asked coach Harbaugh asked
Jim how he knew what the size of the the
papal puts out the Pope's foot size is
his wife did the spade work on behalf
and that he had to get a one size larger
than his actual foot because the Pope
wears orthotics Reese that information
just just somehow someway quote the rich
eyes and show on that when you use that
okay Reese I will do that that's perfect
I love that okay very good
I'll amend I look forward to watching
your coverage and I'll get one last
thing to Reese in all seriousness as
well what about the tweeting as the Lee
is NBA as the NBA told ESPN to stay away
from tweeting even though everybody else
is doing it during the draft I wouldn't
say that they've told us to stay away
from it rich I think what I think what's
happened is we sort of made a decision
that you know you want the announcer you
want the moment you want the moment on
television so they go ahead and do it
now if a reporter digs it up
independently nobody's putting putting
the muzzle on anyone
from tweaking it out meaning you know
you know how these things work from from
your work on the NFL Draft at some point
people have to know who for the pick is
Amanda picks it and that type of thing I
think is not where the news is being
broken but somebody gets it from a
general manager or somebody in the room
or player agent they put it out they put
it out you know so we try not to worry
about that too much but we also just
from the viewing experience
give it a moment and let them do it
there was five minutes between rounds
here in two minutes in the second so you
know you're not you're not killing
anybody you're holding news back for the
most part by the time those picks rancer
have a great broadcast Reese thanks for
pirates thanks but you got a breach
Davis joining us Jay Bilas on that
broadcast tonight will be on our show
tomorrow the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on radio stations across
the country
and audience if you like that please
download our app there's lots of fun
things there other than just more of the
videos you just saw you can call us from
the app you can email us from the app
just download it trust me you'll enjoy